Il y a une ou deux questions ici, mais s'il y a d'autres questions qui peuvent survenir après, nous pourrons, disons, nous divertir avec.
Comment peut-on créer des formations karmiques ?
Sankara.
Oui, des formations karmiques.
Et après ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut expérimenter ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on s'appelle ?
Bavanga.
C'est-à-dire, le flux ?
Bien, laissez-moi répondre à la deuxième question, Bavanga.
Bavanga signifie...
Le baranga signifie le facteur du redevenir, le lien.
Le lien, oui.
Ceci est en relation avec l'Abhidhamma, qui est la dernière partie de l'enseignement du Bouddha.
Non, après le Bouddha.
Il est venu parce qu'il y avait un grand intérêt
en essayant de décrire ce qu'était la Conscience.
Ce qu'elle consistait, à combien ça a duré.
Donc maintenant,
Dans un moment de conscience, il y a dix-sept parties.
Je ne me souviens pas des dix-sept parties.
Mais je peux vous donner l'outil.
Quand nous entendons quelque chose, la première chose qu'on perçoit, c'est un bruit.
Gromming, oui.
Disons, c'est un genre de battement de tambour.
Un battement.
Ça, vous pourrez expérimenter dans votre méditation.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que le Vénérable invente.
Quand une vague, disons, du son vient et vous ressentez comme un toucher,
À ce moment-là, la conscience est réveillée par le contact, le battement.
Quand le contact est établi,
Comment ça s'appelle ?
Il vient dans l'esprit ?
Il est attrapé dans l'esprit ?
Il est absorbé par l'esprit ?
C'est comme si quelqu'un frappe à votre porte et que vous l'invitez à entrer.
La prochaine chose que vous percevez est le son d'une cloche.
Voilà, après vient le mot, la perception, disons, du son de la cloche.
À ce moment-là vient, disons, le sens, le son est égal, disons, au réveil ou bien à la cloche.
La cloche, le réveil.
Après, vous avez, disons, bien après la signification « réveillez-vous ».
Après, bien, disons, « moi, je dois me lever ».
Et puis après, ça s'arrête là.
La prochaine pensée, c'est de se lever.
Maintenant, entre
Entre les deux intervalles des deux pensées, l'esprit s'arrête.
Dans les dix-sept parties du moment de conscience, il y en a un.
Trois qui sont, disons, au commencement et trois, disons, à la fin.
À ce moment-là, à cet intervalle-là, l'esprit s'arrête, l'esprit, disons, se repose.
Ce qu'ils appellent ces trois moments, c'est le lien, disons, de la conscience.
Ça, c'est le Bhavanga.
Le sommeil, disons, c'est le Bhavanga.
Le sommeil profond.
Disons, à ce moment-là, disons, il n'y a rien, mais l'esprit est toujours là.
Alors, s'il n'y a pas de conscience, à ce moment-là, vous n'entendrez pas le son du réveil, de la cloche.
Oui ?
La question est-ce qu'on peut expérimenter Bhavanga ?
On ne peut pas le faire de manière objective.
Dans le sommeil normal.
Mais dans une très bonne méditation, si votre méditation est très bonne, vous pouvez vous trouver vous-même en sommeil.
Dans une méditation qui est très raffinée, vous pourrez vous retrouver éveillé dans le sommeil.
Et vous pourrez expérimenter l'esprit comme un flot d'énergie, il n'y a rien dedans.
Vous allez être conscient, vous allez savoir que vous êtes endormi.
Il n'y a pas de mots.
Parce que l'esprit, le corps, est immobile, mais vous êtes éveillé.
Dans la même manière que beaucoup d'autres personnes expérimentent... Qu'est-ce qu'ils appellent ça ?
Quand vous vous réveillez dans un rêve.
Lucid dreaming, merci beaucoup.
Oui, donc vous êtes là, vous voyez le rêve, vous l'entendez.
Mais généralement, nous n'expérimentons pas Bhavanga comme objet.
Mais disons, de manière générale, on n'expérimente pas le Bhavanga comme un objet mental.
Comment ne pas créer des formations karmiques Sankara ?
Pour comprendre ça, il faudrait revenir sur l'explication des cinq accrégats, des morceaux, des cinq morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux, des morceaux.
On l'appelle le khanda.
Khanda.
Ou pour les Tibétains, skhanda.
Ou bien, aux Tibétains, skhanda.
Vous avez vu ça ?
Skhanda.
Ah, d'accord.
Donc, le premier khanda, c'est le premier morceau, sont toutes ces choses qui ont à voir avec ce que nous appelons le corps.
Notre nature physique.
Le premier intégral est appelé le corps, le corps physique.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent tout cela, cela réfère vraiment aux quatre grands éléments.
La qualité de la chaleur.
La qualité du feu.
La qualité, disons, de ce qui est léger et de ce qui est lourd, c'est-à-dire de la gravité.
Ce qu'on appelle l'élémentaire.
La qualité du mouvement.
Ce qu'on appelle l'élément air.
Le vent, oui.
Le vent ou l'air ?
La qualité de ce qui est cohérent, disons de ce qui se colle, comme du chewing-gum.
Cohésion, oui.
C'est l'eau.
C'est l'eau ?
C'est l'eau, oui.
Non, oui, non, le chewing-gum est un exemple.
Non, le chewing-gum, c'est un exemple.
Le Bouddha, je ne pense pas qu'il y a eu le chewing-gum.
Bon, Bernard, je pense qu'à l'époque du Bouddha, il n'y a pas encore le chewing-gum.
Donc, c'est ce que nous appelons le Rupa, le corps, la physicalité.
Le prochain est tout à fait lié au ressenti.
C'est les sensations qui proviennent du corps, plaisantes et désagréables.
Oui, comme la douleur dans le nez ou la nourriture sur votre langue, plaisantes.
Comme la douleur à votre genou ou bien le goût de la nourriture sur votre langue, c'est agréable.
Et cela aussi se réfère à la sensation de votre vie émotionnelle, agréable ou désagréable.
Et toutes les sensations qui viennent du corps et qui sont neutres.
Tout ça constitue vedanā.
Tout ça, ce sont les sensations, disons, qui viennent du corps.
Il y a une autre word, une autre word pour « feeling » ?
Une autre word ?
Sensation.
Non, non, non, perception.
Ok.
Le prochain accrégat, ce sont nos perceptions.
Disons d'abord, il y a les perceptions de base qui sont les perceptions des couleurs et des formes.
Sanya, ça s'appelle Sanya.
Le quatrième accrégat, c'est Sankara que nous allons discuter.
Le cinquième accrégat, c'est la conscience.
Chaque fois qu'il y a un objet,
La conscience apparaît en même temps.
C'est un acte de reconnaissance, de savoir.
une section spéciale.
Toutes les autres sections apparaissent que nous l'aimons ou non.
Oui, tant que vous avez un corps, il y aura des ressentis, des perceptions et des connaissances.
Tant que vous avez un corps, vous avez les sensations, les perceptions et la conscience.
Ce sont les éléments qui constituent Sankara.
Sankara est en plus.
On prend tous ces éléments et après on va, disons, développer
Ce sont des états mentaux et la manière dont nous créons le monde.
Ça, c'est Sankara.
Quand nous entrons dans cette chambre-là, dans cette salle, tout de suite il y a la perception, disons, et la sensation qu'on a de la salle.
Et puis, après, on commence à avoir des idées.
Ça, ce sont nos sankharas.
Les sankharas, c'est ce qu'on crée.
C'est quelque chose que nous créons.
Et ce fait de la création
est d'abord un acte conscient.
Oui, c'est un acte conscient, volontaire.
C'est un acte volontaire, intentionnel.
Par exemple, quand nous apprenions à rouler un vélo,
Quand on commence à apprendre, disons, à aller en vélo, on doit pratiquer de manière consciente et délibérée jusqu'au moment où on peut rouler en bicyclette.
Après ça, ça devient automatique.
Alors il y a un moment de notre vie où nous nous disons à nous-mêmes comment nous sommes en colère, disons, ou bien déprimés.
ou bien créer des actes qui ne sont pas du tout efficaces.
Et que nous décidons aussi, disons, d'être...
d'avoir l'amour universel, disons la compassion, les sentiments amicaux et toutes ces décisions deviennent, disons, nos habitudes et ces habitudes sont tellement enfouies en nous-mêmes que nous ne sommes plus conscients
Et nous posons la question pourquoi beaucoup de monde ne veulent pas nous comprendre.
Et après, nous sommes surpris pourquoi beaucoup de monde, disons, nous offre des services.
La plupart du temps, nous ne sommes pas conscients de nos traits de caractère.
Part of the meditation is to make ourselves to become much more aware as to what are our driving motivations which are subliminal
disons, une partie de la méditation est de découvrir ce qui nous fait, comment ça s'appelle, avancer et qui est subliminal.
Subliminal, yes.
Freud le comprend très bien.
Parfois, dans votre vie, vous découvrez
que, disons, il y a certaines choses que vous ne voulez pas, qu'il y a une résistance de votre part d'accomplir ces choses-là.
Nous...
Nous percevons tout de suite la résistance, nous acceptons, disons, de ne pas le faire, et nous en allons.
On ne va pas, disons, mettre en question cette résistance.
Nous assumons que cette résistance, elle est normale et correcte.
Par exemple, quand je fais mes rétreats Mahasi, on arrive le matin à 3h30, 4h00.
Beaucoup de gens disent que c'est impossible.
Je ne peux pas faire ça.
Si ils étaient en train d'acheter un avion à Malaga, oh, ils arrivent à 2h00 le matin.
Mais s'ils doivent prendre un avion pour aller à Malaga, à deux heures du matin, ils se réveilleront.
Mais pour une retraite méditative, pour eux, c'est trop tôt.
Et quand ils...
Quand le vénérable demande pourquoi il y a cette résistance, ils ont déjà une phrase toute faite dans leurs esprits.
Disons, cette phrase-là a pour origine, disons, leur enfance.
Ils ont besoin de huit heures de sommeil.
Huit heures !
un tiers de leur vie, disons, à dormir, c'est-à-dire être, comment ça s'appelle ?
Mort.
Partie de mort.
Toutes ces formations karmiques sont, disons, fabriquées par nous-mêmes.
Le corps est un accident génétique.
Mes yeux ne peuvent voir seulement ce que ma rétine perçoit.
Si je ne peux pas voir les couleurs, je ne peux pas voir les couleurs.
Il y a des choses de base que je ne peux rien faire et que, disons que je me trouve avec ça.
La culture dans laquelle je me trouve, disons, je ne l'ai pas choisie,
Vous voyez ?
Il y a beaucoup de zones dans ma vie qui ne sont pas sous mon contrôle.
Quand je regarde les choses que je crée, mes états mentaux
Si je regarde ce que je crée, ce sont mes états mentaux.
Et quand je vais méditer et je découvre avec horreur que c'est des états mentaux, je ne peux pas non plus les contrôler.
Et je crée un marma, disons, dans mon esprit et dans mon cœur.
Ces habitudes, ces états mentaux,
ont après une vie, disons, en elles-mêmes et ils ont une énergie pour elles-mêmes.
Comment je peux arrêter ces habitudes qui ne sont pas efficaces, qui sont impures ?
Celles qui sont pures, je veux bien les garder.
Quand le Bouddha est éveillé, cela ne signifie pas que toutes ses formations mentales se sont arrêtées.
C'est le pas que le Bouddha, disons, ne peut plus réfléchir et devient un bloc.
Il n'était pas comme s'il ne pouvait pas ressentir, ressentir les sentiments de d'autres personnes, ressentir son propre cœur.
Il ne peut pas ressentir les autres.
Quand il parle de lui-même, il dit que ce qu'un maître peut faire avec la compassion pour ses étudiants, c'est ce qu'il a fait pour nous.
Il a dit que ce qu'un maître...
Et le mot qu'il utilise n'est pas Karuna, le mot habituel, compassion, il utilise le mot Anukampa.
disons, le mot qu'il utilise, ce n'est pas mukharuna, mais... Anukampa.
Anukampa.
Ça signifie venir vers les autres, c'est-à-dire l'empathie.
L'empathie.
Vous voyez ?
Donc, le processus de méditation, le processus d'enlever ces formations karmiques, ne nous conduit pas à une sorte de mort ou d'annihilation,
Ce processus de nouer ces formations karmiques, ce n'est pas aller vers une cessation, disons, un immobilisme, disons, une mort.
Ça nous conduit à avoir un cœur plein de bonté, de compassion, de joie.
de paix, de joie, d'amour.
Et ce processus est un processus de transformation.
Ce qui est en nous, la haine, disons, la...
Anger.
La colère va être transformée en amour.
Cruelty to compassion, selfishness to generosity.
Cruelty en compassion.
Comment ça s'appelle ?
Égoïsme.
Égoïsme en bonté.
Hum.
C'est pas une générosité, yes.
Ces sankhāras, nous les avons créés mais ils sont basés sur l'illusion.
Délusion.
Aversion.
Acquisition.
Acquisition, saisie.
Greed.
Greed, hatred and delusion.
Disons, combatisme.
Oui.
Donc, ce que nous commençons, excusez-moi, ce que nous commençons à comprendre, c'est que, une fois que nous avons mis en oeuvre le véhicule, même si vous mettez le frein, il ira toujours.
Disons,
Dès qu'on avait mis en marche la voiture, même si on veut l'arrêter en arrivant sur les freins, elle continue à rouler.
Dès que nous avons créé en nous, disons, la colère, la dépression,
toutes les misères humaines tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est de lever les pieds de l'accélérateur c'est-à-dire d'arrêter de les oublier alors mettez-vous en colère il faut dire non, non, non mais vous devez laisser l'angue se manifester
Mais on doit laisser, disons, la colère se manifester.
Mais ne pas les laisser manifester en paroles et en actions, parce que, disons, avec ce processus, on est en train de recréer
Mais vous devez le permettre de se manifester comme une sensation.
Toutes les émotions sont une forme d'énergie.
Comme le système de l'hiver.
Parfois c'est comme ça et parfois c'est chaud.
C'est comme la météo, parfois il y a du vent, parfois c'est chaud.
Quoi qu'il en soit, disons, de la météo, vous avez à faire ce que vous devrez faire.
En vous, vous subissez toujours les variations météorologiques.
Parfois il y a une dépression atmosphérique, disons, et parfois il y a du soleil.
Notre... disons...
Le but, c'est, disons, c'est d'observer, d'être en position d'observateur, d'expérimenter, de noter, mais de ne pas être entraîné.
Quand nous sommes en train de faire la méditation assise ou bien marchée, pour maintenir cet état, disons, mental immobile,
et de laisser apparaître les formations mentales et de les laisser disparaître.
Mais nous ne pouvons pas faire cet effort quand vous traversez la rue.
Vous ne pouvez pas s'arrêter au milieu de la rue et observer la colère surgir et disparaître.
Dans la vie de tous les jours, on sait, disons, les formations mentales
Dans la vie de tous les jours, on sait qu'il y a la colère, la dépression, disons l'anxiété.
Mais ils restent avec nous comme des petits chiens.
Ils peuvent disons aboyer, pleurer, mais ils sont toujours là.
Mais votre attention et intention
va venir de la sagesse.
Si vous êtes au travail et que tout d'un coup vous avez, comment ça s'appelle ?
L'ennui, oui.
L'ennui, c'est un état, disons, de haine.
C'est une aversion.
Donc,
Je suis en train de faire mon travail et je me sens ennuyé.
L'ennui va me dire, allez, faites quelque chose.
Disons, merveilleux et distrayant.
Smoking, shopping, drinking.
Et puis, bien sûr, vous perdez votre travail.
Donc maintenant, au lieu d'être contrôlé par le bourdon, nous voyons le bourdon comme juste ce...
Disons, au lieu d'être contrôlé par l'ennui, on doit le considérer comme un gros, un chien d'odieux.
Il est avec nous, le chien d'odieux.
Mon attention,
disons, va être focalisée sur mon travail, ainsi que mon intention qui provient, disons, de la sagesse.
Je fais mon travail comme un service rendu aux autres et à moi-même,
Disons, par compassion, par amour.
Lentement, les vieilles habitudes vont disparaître d'elles-mêmes.
les bonnes habitudes vont prendre prise.
Avec ces Sankaras, on voit qu'on peut
mon esprit et mon cœur je peux le recréer donc c'est quelque chose que nous devons prendre la responsabilité pour ça c'est de notre responsabilité donc vous ne pouvez pas de maintenant vous ne pouvez pas dire à vos collègues à votre partenaire à votre espouse vous me faites malheur
à partir de maintenant vous ne pouvez plus dire disons que c'est la faute disons provient de vos collègues de votre conjoint et que disons que ce sont eux qui sont responsables de votre colère vous êtes la cause de mon disons de mes problèmes disons de mon disons de ma tristesse pitié
Que marre !
Ces formations karmiques sont nos habitudes.
Toutes ces habitudes constituent notre personnalité, nos traits de caractère.
Une fois que nous avons une personnalité et un caractère, cela nous conduira à notre destinée.
Quand on a ces traits de caractère, elles vont nous conduire vers notre destin.
C'est très important de définir nos traits de caractère et de les transformer.
Où est-ce qu'on commence ?
À partir de l'intention.
L'intention.
C'est pour cela que, quand je m'appuie sur cela, pour que les gens notent l'intention, l'intention de marcher.
Si il n'y a pas d'intention, vous ne marchez pas.
Donc, à la maison, vous voyez, vous ne pourrez pas attraper, vous ne pourrez pas attraper l'intention.
Peut-être, à la maison, vous n'attrapez pas, vous n'êtes pas conscient de l'intention.
Et déjà, quand vous en êtes conscient, vous avez déjà une autre tasse de café.
Ce sont les habitudes.
Et quand nous avons, disons, attrapé l'intention, c'est-à-dire être conscient de l'intention, nous avons le pouvoir.
Disons là, à l'entretien de l'intention,
survient, nous pouvons demander est-ce que c'est efficace, c'est pas efficace, est-ce que c'est pur ou c'est impur.
Alors on peut dire trop de café, j'arrête.
Ou bien je peux dire que j'ai besoin du café pour rester éveillé.
Vous voyez ?
Vous pouvez prendre une décision.
Mais une fois que vous avez empouvé une intention, vous l'avez perdue, vous êtes en retard.
Quand on a donné du pouvoir, disons, à une intention, on a perdu nous-mêmes le contrôle.
Le point où on donne le pouvoir, disons, à une intention, ça c'est un acte karmique.
C'est cet acte de volonté que j'appelle un acte de kamma.
Et à ce point, vous vous conditionnez, vous conditionnez.
Et c'est ainsi que nous créons ces formations karmiques.
Enfin,
Toutes ces actes karmiques proviennent de la notion, disons, de ce que nous sommes, ce qui est une, disons, d'une délusion.
Une délusion de ce que nous sommes vraiment.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le moi, le soi.
Quand nous sommes complètement libérés du soi, du moi, il y aura encore des formations karmiques, mais comme il n'y a plus de moi, il n'y aura plus d'attachement.
Dans l'Abhidharma, il y a distinction entre les actes qui sont commis par les gens qui sont ignorants et les actes qui sont commis par les gens qui sont éveillés.
Il y a un nouveau mot qui s'appelle Kriya pour expliquer cette différence.
Ça va ?
Je ne suis pas si motivé à méditer tous les jours.
Je ne suis pas très motivé pour moi d'éteindre tous les jours.
Je ne suis pas content parce que je ne suis pas constant.
Je ne suis pas content parce que je ne suis pas consistant.
Je trouve toutes sortes d'excuses pour ne pas méditer.
Comme aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que vous pouvez m'aider à me motiver et à me discipliner ?
Disons, j'ai peur, je crains d'écouter ma voix intérieure.
Eh bien, quand vous me demandez si je peux vous aider, ce que vous pouvez faire, c'est ceci.
Faites une très forte détermination pour méditer pendant un certain temps chaque jour, peut-être une demi-heure du matin ou une heure du matin, ce que vous savez que vous pouvez faire.
D'abord, il faut avoir une résolution très forte de méditer une certaine période de tous les jours, une demi-heure le matin ou bien une heure le matin.
Chaque fois que vous n'arrivez pas, il faudrait envoyer au Vénérable 100 francs.
alors je devrais développer votre propre discipline il faut commencer petit et pas de manière ambitieuse même 10 minutes mais il faut le faire de manière religieuse absolument religieusement
à moins pendant six mois.
Et après, ça devient une habitude, c'est-à-dire un sankara.
Même si vous manquez une ou deux fois, votre corps va vous pousser à le faire.
C'est beaucoup plus efficace, disons, de méditer tout au long de la journée que de méditer seulement, disons, une longue durée.
Le matin, seulement le matin.
Le matin que vous méditez, c'est pour vous rappeler et pour que vous accédez, disons, à ce niveau de conscience.
Et pendant la journée, une minute, deux minutes, juste seulement pour retrouver ce niveau de conscience.
Il y a de nombreuses fois que vous pouvez le faire.
Et vous pouvez le faire, pas seulement en se assis, mais en marchant.
Juste pensez à combien de fois vous marchez à l'extérieur, ou vous marchez de ce endroit à cet endroit, et votre esprit est partout.
Vous rappelez combien de fois vous escaladez les escaliers, les marches, ou bien que vous allez d'un endroit à l'autre, mais que votre esprit est partout ?
À ce moment-là, il faudrait recentrer sur votre corps et être conscient de ce que vous faites.
Demain, on va faire ce qu'on n'a pas fait aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire la méditation sur l'amour universel.
Vous pouvez aussi développer cela durant toute la journée.
Vous savez, ces temps où, normalement, nous laissons le mental s'éloigner.
Surtout, disons, dans les moments où votre esprit vagabonde.
Par exemple, quand vous êtes assis dans le tramway ou bien quand vous êtes assis dans la voiture en attendant les feux.
Vous pourrez offrir votre amour immense à tous ceux qui souffrent.
À tous les misérables.
Quand vous rentrez du travail et que vous êtes encore un peu frais, vous pouvez faire un petit peu de méditation.
10 minutes, 15 minutes.
Ce n'est pas nécessaire que ce soir, disons...
Disons, il faudrait essayer de libérer tout ce qui vous a accumulé durant la journée pour qu'il vienne et se dissipe.
Et l'irritation, angoisse,
Et après, vous allez avoir une bonne soirée.
Ok.
J'ai peur
Écoutez ma voix intérieure.
Ça, c'est la bonne voix qui vous demande, qui vous dit de méditer.
À ce moment-là, vous devrez l'écouter.
Comment surmonter la fatigue quand on médite de longue durée ?
Si ce n'est pas de la fatigue, à ce moment-là, il faudrait ouvrir les yeux, mettre un peu plus d'énergie et vous mettre debout.
À ce moment-là, il faudrait prendre une très ferme résolution.
De ne pas ?
Annihilé.
Ah, de ne pas être annihilé, oui.
Annihanté, oui.
Oui.
Quand vous sentez de la douleur dans les jambes, par exemple, qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
Est-ce qu'on doit bouger ?
First of all,
vous l'utilisez pour comprendre le processus de la douleur et de la souffrance.
Ce sont deux choses différentes.
D'abord, il faudrait l'utiliser pour comprendre ce que c'est la douleur et la souffrance.
La douleur est normale, disons, pour le corps.
Même le Bouddha est mort très inconfortablement.
Même le Bouddha est mort, disons, de manière confortable.
Est-ce que ça, c'est la souffrance ?
Nous souffrons plus avec notre relation avec la douleur.
La souffrance, c'est quelque chose que nous créons.
Ça, c'est l'aversion, disons, la peur, le rejet.
Quand la douleur arrive, l'aversion surgit, il faut très compte observer l'aversion et attendre qu'elle disparaisse et revenir sur la douleur.
Quand nous revenons sur la douleur, la douleur augmente.
La peur se vient et on pense que notre pied va exploser.
Le genou.
Et le pied.
Nous notons la peur et nous revenons sur la douleur.
Quand la peur et l'aversion disparaissent, quand je peux rester assis en paix avec la douleur,
A ce moment-là, je vais entrer dans la douleur pour découvrir la composition de la douleur, comment elle est faite.
que je vais découvrir seulement, disons, la pression et la chaleur et quand je vais noter chaleur et pression, l'idée de douleur disparaît alors je vais réaliser que tout ça c'est créé par l'esprit
Maintenant, si vous ne pouvez pas faire cette investigation parce que la douleur est trop grande, alors vous pouvez bouger.
Mais quand vous faites cette investigation, vous ne méditez plus, vous essayez juste de... Non ?
Vous savez ce que je veux dire ?
Non ?
La question c'est que quand vous investiguez la douleur, vous ne méditez plus parce que vous êtes en train de l'analyser.
Nous ne sommes pas en train, disons, d'établir un état mental idéal.
Ça, c'est une autre sorte de méditation.
Quand nous faisons la méditation, disons l'amour universel, nous créons un état mental idéal, mais
Mais dans le cadre de l'investigation, disons, nous analysons la douleur.
Et la question fondamentale pour le Bouddha, c'est pourquoi nous souffrons.
Just a quick follow-up question.
So, when you feel the pain in your knee,
et que vous sentez que vous en avez peur ou que vous n'aimez pas ça se manifeste dans un autre endroit dans le corps, ce n'est probablement pas votre genou.
Non.
Vous sentez une douleur dans votre genou est-ce que ça se manifeste ailleurs que... Non, non, non.
Donc, ma question est si c'est
C'est-à-dire qu'à ce moment-là, vous allez venir de la douleur et vous revenez vers la sensation de peur.
Nous devrons, disons, trouver, disons, qu'est-ce que c'est la peur et qui a peur.
Est-ce qu'on peut être, est-ce qu'on peut côtoyer la peur, disons, de manière sans peur ?
Si on n'a plus la peur, disons, peur de la peur, disons, de quoi on aura peur ?
Je crois que c'était le Président Roosevelt.
Il a dit que la seule chose dont nous devons avoir peur, c'est la peur.
Je crois qu'il était un bouddhiste.
Donc, d'accord ?
Alors, à ce moment-là, il faudrait partager tous les mérites que vous accumulez aujourd'hui à tous les êtres humains.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
karaniyam gathaku salena yantam santam padam gabhi-sameca sako uju ca suju ca suvaco ca samudu anati mani
SANTUSAKOCHA SUBHAROCHA APAKICHOCHA SALAUKAUTI SANTENRIOCHA NIPACOCHA APAGABHOKULESU ANANUGIDO
Nācchā kūdāṃ samācchāre kañcchī yena viṇyūpāre upāvādeyum sukhino vākemi nohaṃ tu sābe sātā bhavantū sukhi tathā ye ke cipā na bhūtāti tāsa vāta vāra vāna vāse sā
Dīgāvā ye mahantavā majjhī marasakānukatulā Dītāvā ye vādītā ye cāduré vāsanti āviduré Bhūtāvā sambhāvaisi vāsabhesatā bhavantu sukhi tathā
nāpāro pārāṁ nīkubheta nāti mānyetā kathāci nēnkeñci biharo sannāpati gāsānyā nānyamānyā sādhukāmi ca yā
Madayadhani yamputham ayusai kaputham anurake hevampi sababuthesu manasambhavaye aparimanam metenca sabalokasmi manasambhavaye aparimanam
utaṁ gādo ca tīriyāṁ ca asampātāṁ gāvairāṁ gāsapātāṁ titāṁ ca rāṇḍi-sīno vāsāyāṇo vāyāvatāsavigatām idaḥ etāṁ satiṁ āditeyā prakmaṁ etāṁ vihāraṁ gīdām ahū
DITINCHA ANUPAGAMA SILAVADASANENA SAMPHANO KAMESU VINEYA GEDANG NA HIJATU GAVASEYANG PUNARE TITI
Bhavatus abha-mangalang rakantu sabha-devata sabha-buddhanu bhavena sadhasoti bhavantute bhavatus abha-mangalang rakantu sabha-devata sabha-dhammanu bhavena sadhasoti bhavantute
Sous-titrage Société Radio-Canada